America did you know any of these women
before filming no like no I didn't know
Margo at all Isa maybe we like said hi
at events we were on a whole panel
together America it's fine
I wasn't memorable
that is like a real friend the one in
like Boston well now you know no I do
remember
okay yes okay but she's like long answer
I knew everyone so but this is my
problem because actually my story about
Kate is that I saw her
um uh I saw her at an event and I
thought oh my God that's Kate McKinnon I
have to go say hi and I walked up and I
was like Kate I am your biggest fan and
she's like America
you don't remember and I was like oh no
what we but you went by a different last
name sure and when we were in high
school we attended the same drama summer
program at Northwestern University okay
and it was like one of those moments in
the movie where like your mind rewinds
quickly and forward and then things make
sense and I go you're Kate you're funny
Kate you're the funniest person that was
at the camp and also the funniest person
I'd ever met to that date and of course
you're Kate McCain but I but I remember
because America was in we were all had
our separate shows right and America did
like the most amazing dramatic monologue
and everyone was like America and I was
like oh my God America and I was um I
played a bug in my show and so but it
was like yeah I'm just gonna not be
offended when I see America tomorrow
she's like and you are here
but as a joke I forget everyone it's
okay it's a joke should have been like
welcome to the show you've never been
here the truth is last night I like
tried to Envision what this was going to
feel like and I thought if Little
America knew that she was standing next
or sitting next to these four people who
I truly deeply deeply like admire and
idolize yeah I like was crying in bed
last night thinking about so this is
like a dream and this is a Dreamcast
this is what making the movie felt like
it was like how how our it's a dream I
love that
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
guys I'm going
home
[Music]